♪♪♪
HI, EVERYBODY.
FROM THOUSANDS OF APPLICANTS
TO 13 FINALISTS,
THIS SEARCH FOR
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL
HAS BEEN A SEASON
OF WILD FIRSTS.
- (horse neighs)
- OH, MY GOD!
FROM IMPLANTS...
JANICE KNOWS
ALL ABOUT THIS STUFF.
TO TALKING TO PLANTS...
I FEEL LIKE ME AND COUSIN ITT
ARE ALMOST THE SAME.
AND FROM WALKOUTS...
SO YOU'RE NOT READY
TO CUT YOUR HAIR?
NO!
TO FAKE OUTS.
BOTH OF YOU MUST PACK
YOUR BAGS
BECAUSE WE'RE
ALL GOING TO LONDON.
YEAH, YEAH, YEAH!
ONLY THREE GIRLS REMAIN--
NICOLE, BRE AND NIK.
AND TONIGHT ONE OF THEM
WILL BE NAMED
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
WILL IT BE NICOLE,
THE COLLEGE STUDENT
FROM GRAND FORKS,
NORTH DAKOTA?
RIGHT FROM THE START,
IT WAS APPARENT
HOW MUCH
THE CAMERA LOVED HER.
NICOLE, THIS IS THE BEST SHOT
WE'VE SEEN OF ANYBODY YET.
BUT AS THE COMPETITION
WORE ON, THE JUDGES WONDERED
HOW MUCH NICOLE LOVED
THE CAMERA BACK.
I FEEL LIKE YOU'RE STILL
RESTING ON PRETTY,
AND NOT PUSHING THROUGH.
(screams)
BEAUTY'S JUST NOT ON
THE OUTSIDE, IS IT?
NO, IT'S NOT.
TONIGHT, NICOLE NEEDS
TO PROVE TO THE JUDGES
THAT SHE'S MORE THAN
JUST A PRETTY FACE.
WILL IT BE BRE,
THE SASSY GIRL FROM HARLEM
WHOSE SIGNATURE WALK
AND SEDUCTIVE PERSONALITY
MADE HER STAND OUT
FROM THE CROWD?
BUT FROM
THE FIRST PHOTO SHOOT,
BRE STRUGGLED TO TAKE
A GOOD PICTURE.
I'M DESCENDING DOWN
TO TAKE A DUMP
ON THE SUPERHERO THRONE.
THIS IS NOT
WHAT I EXPECTED IT TO BE,
SO I GOT TO SHAPE UP.
BUT RATHER THAN GIVE UP,
BRE DUG DEEP
AND STARTED TURNING OUT
FABULOUS PHOTOS.
EVERY WEEK I CALL YOUR NAME,
YOU CAN'T BELIEVE IT,
BUT YOU ARE
IMPROVING SO MUCH.
BRE HAS MADE PROGRESS,
BUT HAS SHE IMPROVED ENOUGH TO
BE AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL?
OR WILL IT BE NIK,
THE SOFT-SPOKEN GIRL
FROM ATLANTA
WHOSE GENTLE PERSONALITY
TURNED FIERCE IN FRONT
OF THE CAMERA?
IN GOING THROUGH YOUR FILM,
YOU DID THE BEST
OUT OF ALL THE GIRLS.
BUT JUDGES STARTED TO REALIZE
THAT ONCE NIK STRUCK A POSE,
IT STUCK--LITERALLY.
I'VE SEEN THIS PICTURE
WEEK AFTER WEEK WITH NIK,
AND IT'S THE SAME...
WHEN YOU'RE CONFIDENT
AND STRONG, YOU MIGHT...
AND BEING A TOP MODEL
IS MORE THAN KNOWING
HOW TO STRIKE
ONE FIERCE POSE.
THE PROBLEM WITH NIK IS A SORT
OF LACK OF SELF-CONFIDENCE.
NIK, FOCUS, PLEASE.
CAN NIK SHOW THE JUDGES
THAT SHE'S GOT THE CONFIDENCE
TO SERVE IT WHEN IT
REALLY COUNTS?
FIND OUT TONIGHT
IN THE SEASON FINALE.
WHO WILL BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL?
♪♪♪
♪ I WANT TO BE ON TOP ♪
♪ YOU WANT TO BE ON TOP ♪
♪ YOU WANT TO BE ON TOP ♪♪
- FINAL THREE!
- THREE!
FINAL THREE! WHOO!
FINAL THREE!
WHOO!
I HAVE MADE "AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL" HISTORY.
I HAVE BEEN IN THE BOTTOM TWO
FOUR TIMES.
WE SEE A LITTLE
SOMETHING SPECIAL IN YOU.
- CONGRATULATIONS.
- YEAH.
I SEE SOMETHING IN ME, TOO.
THE JUDGES THINK
I'M A DUD.
YOU HAVE SHOWN
THAT YOU CAN BE A MODEL,
BUT IT'S UP TO YOU TO SHOW
WAY MORE PERSONALITY.
I DEFINITELY THINK
I HAVE THE PERSONALITY
TO BE AMERICA'S NEXT
TOP MODEL.
I NEED TO SHOW THAT
MORE TO TYRA.
WHOO!
THE FINAL THREE IS HUGE,
BUT AT THE SAME TIME,
IT'S NOT WINNING
THIS COMPETITION.
THERE'S A HUGE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN FINAL THREE AND WINNER,
AND I'M GONNA BE
THE WINNER.
TYRA MAIL.
"TRUE BEAUTY COMES
FROM A SOLID FOUNDATION.
BE READY AT 6:00 am."
COME ON, GUYS.
WE GOT TO GO.
GOOD MORNING.
SO DO YOU GUYS KNOW
WHY YOU'RE HERE TODAY?
COVER GIRL!
THE COVETED
COVER GIRL CONTRACT.
AND KEEP IN MIND, THE PHOTO
SHOOT THAT WE DO TODAY
IS GOING TO APPEAR
AS A NATIONAL AD.
COUPLED WITH THIS
WE'RE SHOOTING A COMMERCIAL
FOR COVER GIRL TRUBLEND
POWDER FOUNDATION.
COVER GIRL TRUBLEND
POWDER FOUNDATION
IS THE LATEST ADDITION
TO JOIN THE TRUBLEND
FAMILY OF PRODUCTS.
THIS IS A BIG DEAL.
YOU GIRLS ARE THE FIRST ONES
TO SEE IT,
TRY IT, WORK WITH IT.
THE COMMERCIAL
AND THE PHOTO SHOOT TODAY
ARE ABOUT GIRLS ON THE GO,
BUT THEIR SKIN IS LOOKING
GORGEOUS AND FLAWLESS
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT
TRUBLEND POWDER FOUNDATION DOES.
I THOUGHT WE'D BRING SOMEONE
HERE WHO COULD RELATE
TO WHERE EACH AND EVERY ONE
OF YOU ARE STANDING RIGHT NOW--
THE MOST RECENT WINNER OF
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,
NAIMA!
HEY, GIRLS, HOW ARE YOU?
LOOK! IT'S NAIMA!
I'M REALLY HAPPY
TO SEE NAIMA HERE.
THIS IS A TIME WHERE WE REALLY
NEED TO SEE SOMEBODY
WHO'S BEEN THROUGH THIS
JUST TO SHOW US THAT RAINBOW
'CAUSE ALL WE SEE RIGHT NOW
IS NO FINISH LINE.
THINK ABOUT HOW MUCH YOU
WANT TO BE THE NEXT COVER GIRL
AND REALLY TRANSMIT THAT
IN YOUR PHOTOGRAPHS TODAY.
YOU GUYS UP
FOR THE CHALLENGE?
I'M REALLY EXCITED BECAUSE
I KNOW IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
'CAUSE IT'S COVER GIRL,
SO I WANT TO NAIL IT TODAY.
SO HERE'S YOUR SCRIPT.
IT'S A LITTLE BIT
OF A RHYME.
MOST PEOPLE WOULD DIE
TO HAVE A COSMETICS CONTRACT.
IN THIS CITY, IT'S BETTER
IF YOU DON'T BLEND IN.
YOU'RE NOT NERVOUS
ABOUT THIS, RIGHT?
'CAUSE YOU WERE TERRIFIED
THAT LAST COMMERCIAL.
LET'S NOT TALK ABOUT THAT.
I AM STUDYING LIKE CRAZY
JUST BECAUSE I KNOW
THAT IN THE PAST,
I DIDN'T DO
SO GREAT IN THE COMMERCIAL.
- I'M NERVOUS.
- ME, TOO.
FEEL LIKE YOU KNOW
YOUR STUFF YET, NICOLE?
YEAH.
FOR ME, COVER GIRL
IS LIKE
BRINGING OUT YOUR INNER BEAUTY
AND YOUR TRUE BEAUTY.
I KNOW I DID WELL
WITH MY FIRST COMMERCIAL.
WHAT'S MY SECRET?
HA...
I EAT ICE CREAM IN BED.
I JUST FEEL LIKE I CAN BE
A REAL COVER GIRL.
I FEEL LIKE
I'M GONNA DO WELL.
THIS IS YOUR POSITION
TO LOOK BACK,
SEE WHAT'S GOING ON--
YOU KNOW, LOOK AROUND,
REACT TO EACH OTHER.
I WANT TO BE IN THE MIDDLE.
WE GOTTA LOOK LIKE
WE'RE ONE BIG GANG--
BOYS FLIRTING
WITH THE GIRLS.
YEAH, THERE YOU GO.
THERE YOU GO!
- ACTION.
- LOOK TO CAMERA, GIRLS.
FIRST PART OF OUR COMMERCIAL,
WE WERE INSTRUCTED
BY THE DIRECTOR
TO JUST BE PLAYFUL
WITH EACH OTHER
AND TO POINT TO THINGS
IN THE BACKGROUND.
MIND YOU, NOTHING EXISTS.
LOOK ROUND TO EACH OTHER,
TURN BACK AROUND,
BIG SURPRISE.
EXCELLENT.
TURN SMILING, LIKE...
YEAH.
COVER GIRL.
THAT WAS IT.
SEE THE LITTLE WALL OF--
OF LIGHTS?
YOU'RE LOOKING RIGHT
THROUGH THE MIDDLE OF IT.
SO NOW WE DO THE SECOND PART
OF THE ENTIRE COMMERCIAL.
I'M GOING UP FIRST.
DON'T I LOOK LIKE
TINA TURNER?
ONE, TAKE ONE.
AND ACTION.
THAT'S WHERE TRUBLEND
POWDER FOUNDATION COMES IN.
IT PICKS UP--
(sighs)
WHAT IS IT?
THIS ISN'T LOOKING TOO GOOD
RIGHT ABOUT NOW.
ON THE PLUS SIDE, EVEN THOUGH
YOU'RE STRUGGLING FOR YOUR LINES
YOU LOOK FLAWLESS
ON THE MODELS.
TRUBLEND PICKS UP
YOUR SKIN UNDERTONES,
WHATEVER THEY MAY BE,
AND DUPLICATES THEM
FLAWLESSLY.
ALL RIGHT.
PLEASE LET ME HAVE
A GOOD COMMERCIAL,
'CAUSE THEY'RE GONNA
SEND MY BLACK ASS HOME
- REAL SOON IF I DON'T.
- OKAY.
HE'S SAYING "SAYONARA, BITCH.
YOU'RE OUTTA HERE."
BRE KINDA FUMBLED
HER LINES,
AND NIK IS MAKING SUCH
A BIG DEAL ABOUT THIS
THAT I THINK SHE'S KINDA
LIKE PSYCHING HERSELF OUT.
AND DUPLICATES--
TRUBLEND PICKS UP
YOUR SKIN.
PICKS UP YOUR S--
GOD, THIS IS GONNA BE
DIFFICULT.
I JUST KEEP TELLING MYSELF
"DON'T BE NERVOUS,
DON'T BE NERVOUS.
DON'T BE SCARED,
DON'T BE SCARED."
LET'S SETTLE.
TAKE ONE.
ACTION.
TRUBLEND PICKS UP
YOUR SKIN'S UNDERTONES,
WHATEVER IT MAY BE, AND
DUPLICATES THEM FLAWLESSLY,
EVEN IF NOTHING ELSE
BLENDS IN,
YOU CAN ALWAYS
COUNT ON TRUBLEND.
NEW FROM EASY, BREEZY,
BEAUTIFUL COVER GIRL.
YOU GO, MISS GENIUS.
(applause)
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IT'S REALLY AMAZING
BECAUSE THE COMMERCIAL
IS WHAT I WAS SO TERRIFIED
ABOUT.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE IT
CAME FROM. IT JUST WORKED.
NIK DELIVERED HER LINES
REALLY WELL,
SO NOW I'M KINDA NERVOUS BECAUSE
I KNOW THE PRESSURE'S ON.
- TAKE ONE.
- ACTION.
IN THIS CITY, IT'S BETTER
NOT TO BLEND IN.
EXCEPT, THAT IS,
WHEN IT COMES TO YOUR SKIN.
WITH THE NEW--
OH!
TRY AGAIN.
WITH NEW TRUBLEND--
EVEN IF YOU JUST GET
THE FIRST LINE RIGHT,
THAT WOULD BE GOOD.
SORRY.
EXCEPT, THAT IS,
WHEN IT COMES TO YOUR SKIN.
I AM REALLY FREAKING OUT
RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE I'M JUST SCARED
I'M NOT GOING TO GET THE LINES.
THIS IS THE MOMENT.
CAN YOU TRY AGAIN?
I'M SORRY.
THESE LIGHTS ARE JUST--
THE LIGHTS ARE WHAT?
THEY'RE LIKE BLINDING ME,
KINDA.
YOU GOTTA TRY
AND FOCUS THROUGH IT.
THAT'S WHAT A MODEL'S
GOTTA DO.
♪♪♪
TRY AGAIN.
OKAY, READY?
AND ACTION.
CAN YOU TRY AGAIN?
IT'S VERY CONFUSING HOW
ONE MINUTE, YOU'RE ON THE TOP,
AND THE NEXT MINUTE,
YOU'RE ON THE BOTTOM.
I'M GONNA FEED YOU
EACH SENTENCE, OKAY?
EVEN IF NOTHING ELSE
BLENDS IN,
YOU CAN ALWAYS
COUNT ON TRUBLEND.
NICOLE WALKED ON SET,
AND SHE JUST FROZE.
LAST LINE, THEN.
NEW FROM EASY, BREEZY,
BEAUTIFUL COVER GIRL.
NEW FROM EASY,
BREEZY, BEAUTIFUL COVER GIRL.
I HAD TO FEED HER
EVERY LINE,
AND I'M GONNA HAVE
TO TELL THE JUDGES THAT.
IT FEELS GREAT
TO KNOW THAT I DID WELL
ON THE COVER GIRL
COMMERCIAL.
I'M EXCITED, SO HOPEFULLY,
IT WILL SHOW IN MY PHOTO.
BIG LAUGH.
TRY FIDDLING WITH YOUR HAIR
OR SOMETHING.
THE JUDGES HAVE
TOLD ME THAT I GIVE
THE SAME FACIAL EXPRESSIONS
IN MY PHOTOGRAPHS,
SO IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
FOR ME TO START GIVING VARIETY.
CHIN UP A LITTLE BIT.
YEAH. LOVELY.
ONE MORE.
WELL DONE.
LET'S START OVER THE SHOULDER,
SMILEY, SMILEY.
MY PHOTOGRAPHER TELLS ME
THAT THIS ENTIRE PHOTO SHOOT,
I HAVE TO SMILE.
BIG LAUGH.
I'M TRYING TO THINK OF SOMETHING
REALLY, REALLY FUNNY,
SO IT DOESN'T LOOK
KINDA DEAD AND FORCED.
GREAT.
WELL DONE.
THANK YOU.
I'M ABOUT TO GO
INTO THE PHOTO SHOOT,
AND IT'S SUPER IMPORTANT
THAT I NAIL IT
BECAUSE ON THE COMMERCIAL,
I DIDN'T DO AS GREAT
AS I WANTED TO, AT ALL.
YEAH, WATCH YOUR TONGUE
WHEN YOU SMILE.
YOU PRESS YOUR TONGUE UP
AGAINST THE FRONT OF YOUR TEETH,
- SO YOU SEE IT.
- SORRY.
THAT'S JUST HOW I SMILE,
SO IT'S REALLY HARD FOR ME
TO NOT DO THAT.
LOVELY.
MY PICTURE
HOPEFULLY WAS AMAZING
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT'S
GOING TO SAVE ME.
HOW DID YOU DO TODAY?
I THINK I DID BETTER
ON THE COMMERCIAL
THAN I DID
ON THE PHOTO SHOOT.
- WHAT?
- I REALLY THOUGHT
I WAS GONNA EXPECT THE WORST
PERFORMANCE FROM NIK,
THE BEST PERFORMANCE FROM NICOLE
'CAUSE SHE'S BEEN SO COCKY,
AND BRE TO BE
IN THE MIDDLE.
AND THESE GIRLS ARE JUST
FLIPPING IT UPSIDE DOWN FOR ME,
WHICH GOES TO SHOW
YOU MAY THINK YOU KNOW
WHO'S GONNA BE AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL,
BUT YOU REALLY DON'T.
TYRA MAIL!
"TOMORROW YOU WILL
MEET WITH THE JUDGES.
ONLY TWO OF YOU WILL CONTINUE
IN THE HOPE
OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
ONE OF YOU WILL BE
ELIMINATED."
BRE COULD BE
THE BIGGEST COMPETITION
BECAUSE SHE'S BEEN IN THE BOTTOM
TWO FOUR TIMES IN A ROW.
IT FEELS LIKE MAYBE THEY'RE
KEEPING HER FOR A REASON.
I HOPE
THAT I DON'T GO HOME.
I'M ABOUT THIS CLOSE TO
COMPLETING THIS COMPETITION.
I'M ACTUALLY SUPER NERVOUS
ABOUT THE ELIMINATION.
I REALLY FAILED
AT THE COVER GIRL COMMERCIAL.
I'M PRETTY NERVOUS
ABOUT GOING HOME.
WELCOME, LADIES.
NOW IT'S TIME TO MAKE
OUR TENTH CUT,
WHICH WILL BRING US ONE STEP
CLOSER TOWARDS DETERMINING
WHO WILL BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
AND OF COURSE, YOU'VE GROWN TO
KNOW THESE JUDGES VERY WELL.
FIRST BEING MR. NIGEL BARKER,
NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER.
FASHION DIVA
MISS J. ALEXANDER...
HI, SPANKY.
LEGENDARY FASHION ICON,
TWIGGY,
AND NARGESS GHARANI
AND VANYA STROK.
AND THE TWO FINALISTS
ARE GONNA BE STARRING
IN A GHARANI-STROK
FASHION SHOW.
SO NOW IT IS TIME FOR
YOUR INDIVIDUAL EVALUATIONS.
YOU'LL BE JUDGED ON YOUR
COVER GIRL PHOTO AND COMMERCIAL.
AND HERE'S THE COMMERCIAL,
RIGHT THERE.
IN THIS CITY IT'S BETTER
IF YOU DON'T BLEND IN...
EXCEPT OF COURSE,
WHEN IT COMES FOR YOUR SKIN...
THAT'S WHERE NEW TRUBLEND
POWDER FOUNDATION COMES IN.
TRUBLEND PICKS UP
YOUR SKIN UNDERTONES,
WHATEVER THEY MAY BE...
AND DUPLICATES THEM
FLAWLESSLY.
EVEN IF NOTHING ELSE
BLENDS IN,
YOU CAN ALWAYS
COUNT ON TRUBLEND...
NEW FROM EASY...
- BREEZY...
- BEAUTIFUL...
COVER GIRL.
JUST GAVE ME CHILLS.
YOU GUYS LOOK
LIKE THE RAINBOW--
CHOCOLATE AND VANILLA
AND CARAMEL.
NIK, YOU DID
THE BEST BY FAR,
AND THE COMMERCIAL DIRECTOR
SAID THAT YOU STOOD OUT.
SO, BRE, YOU HAD
A PHOTO SHOOT FOR COVER GIRL.
AND THIS COVER GIRL AD
IS THE FIRST
OF MANY COVER GIRL ADS
FOR THE WINNER
THAT WILL RUN NATIONALLY.
AND HERE IS
YOUR BEST SHOT.
MY ONLY ONE FAULT,
YOU LOOK A LITTLE BIT TIGHT,
STRESSED AROUND THE MOUTH.
THIS IS BACK
TO THE EARLIER ONES,
WHERE YOU LOOK VERY PRETTY.
IT'S INTERESTING, BRE,
BECAUSE WE TOOK FOREVER
FINDING YOUR SHOTS
'CAUSE IT WAS PRETTY, PRETTY,
PRETTY, PRETTY, PRETTY,
BUT THEY WEREN'T NECESSARILY
MODELY-LOOKING.
ALL RIGHT, BRE,
LET'S SEE HOW YOU DID
ON YOUR COMMERCIAL SHOOT.
IN THIS CITY,
IT'S BETTER NOT TO FIT IN.
IT PICKS UP SKIN'S UNDERTONE,
WHATEVER IT IS,
AND DU--
AND DUPLICATES IT.
OH!
EASY, BREEZY, BEAUTIFUL
COVER GIRL.
IT'S A SHAME BECAUSE YOU'VE
ACTUALLY GOT A GREAT VOICE.
YOU WERE GRASPING FOR THE WORDS,
SO THE PERFORMANCE WAS LOST.
WHAT I DID LIKE
ABOUT YOUR RENDITION--
IT WAS VERY PERSONAL.
YOUR PERSONALITY
IS THERE.
UP NEXT IS NIK.
AND HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
- PRETTY.
- OOH! WOW!
IT'S REALLY--IT MAKES ME
WANT TO BE A COVER GIRL.
YOU LOOK LIKE YOU'RE SMILING
AT US, WHICH IS FANTASTIC.
THIS WAS
A BEAUTIFUL SHOT,
BUT THERE WASN'T A LOT
TO CHOOSE FROM.
NOW LET'S SEE HOW YOU DID
ON YOUR COMMERCIAL SHOOT.
EVEN IF NOTHING ELSE
BLENDS IN,
YOU CAN ALWAYS
COUNT ON TRUBLEND.
NEW FROM EASY, BREEZY,
BEAUTIFUL COVER GIRL.
THAT WAS A VERY FLUID
RENDITION.
WHAT WAS NICE IS THAT YOU
MANAGED TO SAY THE WHOLE THING
WITH A SMILE ON YOUR FACE.
THE ONE THING I WOULD SUGGEST
THAT YOU DO IN A COMMERCIAL,
ESPECIALLY FOR A COVER GIRL,
IS BE A LITTLE BIT MORE CHEEKY.
THAT'S WHAT YOU GUYS
CALL IT OVER HERE.
LIKE--YOUR SKIN BLEND IN.
OKAY.
DA-DA-DA.
AND LAST IS NICOLE.
WOW.
OH, THAT'S
ABSOLUTELY GORGEOUS.
YOU LOOK FANTASTIC.
THIS PICTURE IS STUNNING.
ALL RIGHT, NICOLE. LET'S SEE
YOUR COMMERCIAL SHOOT.
IN THIS CITY
IT'S BETTER NOT TO BLEND IN.
EXCEPT, THAT IS, WHEN IT
COMES TO YOUR SKIN.
WITH THE NEW--
OH!
I'M SORRY.
THESE LIGHTS ARE JUST--
THEY'RE LIKE BLINDING ME,
KINDA.
SO THE LIGHTS
WERE BLINDING YOU?
TO BE HONEST, I JUST COULDN'T
REMEMBER THE LINES.
AH, SO YOU BLAMED IT
ON THE LIGHTS.
IT'S A SHAME 'CAUSE YOU
LOOKED REALLY BEAUTIFUL.
IT'S A LOT TO ASK
FROM YOU GUYS.
IT'S NOT A LOT TO ASK.
YOU GUYS ARE HERE BECAUSE
YOU'RE THE BEST GIRLS HERE.
YOU'RE ONE OF THE STRONGEST
GIRLS IN THE SECRET COMMERCIAL.
YOU'RE CHOKING, AND I DON'T
WANT YOU TO WALK OUT OF HERE
AND SAY "OH, IT'S HARD,
AND I COULDN'T DO IT."
YOU HAVE TO TAKE RESPONSIBILITY
AND SAY "NO, I JUST CHOKED."
SO NOW IT'S TIME
FOR THE JUDGES TO DELIBERATE,
AND AFTER THAT, WE'LL DETERMINE
WHICH TWO OF YOU
WILL BE FINALISTS
AND WILL BE ON THE ROAD
TO BECOMING AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL.
ALL RIGHT, SO WE GOT
THREE GIRLS HERE,
BUT ONLY TWO CAN COMPETE
IN YOUR GLORIOUS,
LOVELY FASHION SHOW.
BRE.
SHE'S A GREAT
PHOTOGRAPHIC MODEL.
FOR CAMPAIGNS, I THINK
SHE'D BE BRILLIANT.
THIS IS MY LEAST
FAVORITE SHOT, I HAVE TO SAY.
SHE STILL TO ME
IS NOT A MODEL.
WHEN SHE'S IN FRONT OF YOU,
SHE'S VERY NATURAL,
AND BEING NATURAL
IN FRONT OF THE CAMERA
IS AN IMPORTANT THING.
BRE HAS MORE PUNCH
AND PERSONALITY
THAN NICOLE
AND NIK COMBINED.
- NICOLE.
- NICOLE NEEDS SOME PUNCH
TO GET SOME PERSONALITY.
SHE'S A MODEL TO ME.
SHE ALWAYS LOOKED LIKE A MODEL.
I THINK SHE'S
VERY BEAUTIFUL.
I LOVE HER BODY,
I LOVE HER WALK...
I WOULD HAVE NICOLE
IN MY SHOW.
AND SOMETIMES SHE LOOKS
JUST TOO SWEET AND YOUNG.
WE SAY "OH, SHE'S YOUNG.
SHE'S YOUNG."
MODELS BE STARTIN'
AT 12 YEARS OLD!
- NIK.
- I THINK NIK IS GREAT.
I LOVE THIS PICTURE
OF HER.
BUT NIK'S PERSONALITY IS
SO KIND OF WISHY-WASHY STILL.
WELL, SHE'S BEEN CONSISTENT,
I THINK, THROUGHOUT.
VERY GOOD POINT.
NICOLE AND NIK CONSISTENT,
BRE A LOT OF PROGRESS.
BRE--SHE IS WHO SHE IS,
AND I THINK THAT SOME
OF THE OTHER GIRLS
ARE TRYING TO BE
SOMETHING THEY'RE NOT.
THIS HAS BEEN A REALLY
LONG JOURNEY,
BUT NOW
IT'S DOWN TO THREE.
THREE BEAUTIFUL GIRLS THAT
HAVE PERFORMED MAGNIFICENTLY.
BUT ONE MUST GO HOME.
THE FIRST NAME THAT
I'M GOING TO CALL...
NIK.
IT'S OKAY, NIK.
YOU CAN LET IT OUT.
IT'S OKAY.
YOU'RE A FINALIST.
CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH,
ALL OF YOU.
THANK YOU.
WILL BRE AND NICOLE
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
I HAVE
ONE PHOTO IN MY HANDS,
AND I WILL ONLY CALL
ONE NAME.
THE GIRL
THAT I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY GO
BACK TO YOUR HOTEL,
PACK YOUR BELONGINGS,
AND GO HOME.
YOU GUYS HAVE PERFORMED
IN THE PAST IN A COMMERCIAL,
AND BOTH DID REALLY WELL,
BUT THE COVER GIRL COMMERCIAL,
YOU BOTH DIDN'T DELIVER.
ONE GIRL HAS TAKEN
CONSISTENTLY BEAUTIFUL PICTURES.
BUT THE OTHER GIRL
STARTED WEAKLY,
BUT HER PHOTOS ARE NOW BURNING
BRIGHTLY AND BEAUTIFULLY.
SO WHO IS THE FINALIST?
IS IT THE GIRL
THAT'S BEEN CONSISTENT,
OR IS IT THE GIRL THAT'S
COME A LONG WAY?
THE GIRL THAT
WILL BE JOINING NIK,
AND THAT WILL BE
A FINALIST...
THE GIRL THAT
WILL BE JOINING NIK,
AND THAT WILL BE
A FINALIST...
NICOLE.
YOU SHOULD BE
PROUD OF YOURSELF.
YOU CAN'T FREEZE IN THIS
FINAL FASHION SHOW
LIKE YOU DID
ON THAT COMMERCIAL.
WE WANT TO SEE THAT STRONG,
CONSISTENT GIRL.
- CONGRATULATIONS.
- THANK YOU.
- YOU'RE WELCOME, BRE.
I AM DISAPPOINTED THAT
I DIDN'T WIN THE COMPETITION
BUT I AM VERY GLAD THAT I
MADE IT AS FAR AS I DID HERE.
I CAME A LONG WAY
IN THIS COMPETITION.
THEY TOOK THIS LITTLE
BLACK GIRL FROM HARLEM
AND TOOK HER TO LONDON
TO MODEL.
SHE AIN'T NEVER BEEN
OUT OF THE COUNTRY.
LIFE IS FULL OF
DISAPPOINTMENTS.
TYRA TOLD US HOW MANY DOORS
HAD BEEN SLAMMED IN HER FACE
BEFORE SHE GOT
TO WHERE SHE GOT TO GO.
MY PATH CAN ONLY GO UP
FROM HERE.
IT'S NOTHING BUT UP.
GIRL, CAN YOU BELIEVE IT?
FINAL TWO, YEAH--
ME AND YOU.
MAKING IT
TO THE TOP TWO IS AWESOME
BECAUSE IT GIVES ME
ONE MORE CHANCE TO PROVE
THAT I HAVE WHAT IT TAKES TO BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
ME AND NICOLE,
I DON'T KNOW IF WE'RE FRIENDS.
WE'RE TWO DIFFERENT PEOPLE,
TWO DIFFERENT AGES,
TWO DIFFERENT PLACES IN
OUR LIFE-- NOT MUCH IN COMMON.
WHAT IS YOUR PROBLEM?
HAVE A SENSE OF HUMOR!
I DO.
IT'S NOT FUNNY.
COME ON, GIRL.
NIK JUST KIND OF LIKES TO BE
A LITTLE MORE RESERVED
AND KEEPS TO HERSELF.
I'M JUST NOT AFRAID TO, LIKE,
EMBRACE THE DORK IN ME.
T-MAIL.
TYRA MAIL!
THIS IS PROBABLY
OUR LAST TYRA MAIL.
"YOU CAN'T TELL A BOOK
BY ITS COVER, OR CAN YOU?
BE READY AT 7:45."
- HI.
- HEY.
TODAY THE TRAINING WHEELS
ARE COMING OFF.
I CAN'T BELIEVE THIS.
WE'VE GONE THROUGH
ALL THESE WEEKS.
I ALMOST FEEL
LIKE I WANT TO CRY.
I AM NOT GOING TO BE HERE.
YOU GIRLS ARE GOING TO BE
DOING YOUR PHOTO SHOOT
FOR "ELLE GIRL" MAGAZINE,
SHOT BY GILLES BENSIMON.
SO WHOEVER WINS
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"
IS GONNA HAVE THE WORK
THAT THEY DO IN THERE TODAY
GRACE THE COVER OF "ELLE GIRL"
MAGAZINE IN FEBRUARY 2006.
SO I AM GOING TO TURN YOU GIRLS
OVER TO THE "ELLE GIRL" TEAM.
- HEY.
- HELLO.
BRANDON HOLLY
IS THE EDITOR-IN-CHIEF.
ONE OF YOU IS GONNA BE
ON OUR COVER.
WE DON'T KNOW WHO,
SO BOTH OF YOU HAVE GOT TO ACT
LIKE THIS IS YOUR COVER.
I DO FEEL CONFIDENT THAT I CAN
GET A SUCCESSFUL PHOTO SHOOT
WITHOUT JAY BEING AROUND.
HIS JOB IS DONE,
AND NOW IT'S OUR TURN
TO TAKE WHAT WE'VE LEARNED
AND PUT IT TO USE.
ALTHOUGH I SQUEAKED THROUGH
THE LAST ELIMINATION,
I DIDN'T DO WELL.
I FEEL LIKE I HAVE
A LOT OF WORK TO DO,
BUT I'M KEEPING UP IN SPIRITS
AND BELIEVING IN MYSELF.
- YOU GOOD?
- I'M GOOD.
THAT I LIKE.
- VERY BEAUTIFUL.
- HI!
LOOK WHO I AM SHOOTING WITH?
THIS IS GILLES BENSIMON,
THE GUY THAT I'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT EVERY SINGLE WEEK.
I'M FREAKING OUT
BECAUSE IT'S GILLES BENSIMON.
FINALLY WE GET THE CHANCE
TO WORK WITH HIM.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU GUYS
KNOW THIS ABOUT GILLES,
BUT HE IS A VERY BIG
PRACTICAL JOKER.
THE VERY FIRST TIME
I MET HIM WAS IN PARIS,
I WAS 17 YEARS OLD, AND I
HANDED HIM MY PORTFOLIO.
HE WAS LIKE,
"YOU ARE THE UGLIEST GIRL
I HAVE EVER SEEN IN MY LIFE,"
AND THEN THE NEXT DAY
HE BOOKED ME.
AND HE'S GONNA BE SHOOTING YOUR
"ELLE GIRL" COVER SHOTS TODAY.
AND BY THE WAY, YOU GUYS ARE
DOING THE COVER TRI WITH ME.
OH, MY GOODNESS.
I'M DOIN' THIS PHOTO SHOOT
WITH TYRA.
- WHOO.
- SO YOU GUYS READY?
YEAH.
I'M REALLY FEELING
THE PRESSURE.
I KNOW I HAVE TO DO
A GOOD PHOTO SHOOT.
NICOLE IS DEFINITELY
A BEAUTIFUL GIRL
WITH SO MUCH POTENTIAL.
BUT I'M TRYING
NOT TO FOCUS ON THAT.
I'M TRYING TO FOCUS ON HOW
I CAN MAKE MYSELF SHINE
AND MY PERSONALITY STAND OUT.
EASY... SMILING.
THERE YOU GO, YUP.
JUST DON'T ROLL IT
ALL THE WAY UP.
BUT THAT'S REALLY
GOOD RIGHT THERE.
HEARING GILLES BENSIMON
TELL MY COMPETITOR
IS THE WINNER...
THANK YOU.
...KIND OF THROWS YOU OFF
A LITTLE BIT.
HELLO, AM I STILL HERE?
MY GOAL IS TO WIN,
I HAD TO BE VERY CONFIDENT
TO SHOW TYRA THAT I AM WHO
THEY'RE LOOKING FOR.
OKAY, LET'S GO.
IT'S A LITTLE INTIMIDATING
BEING IN THE TOP TWO WITH NIK.
SHE IS SO BEAUTIFUL.
I LOVE IT.
THAT'S GOOD.
CHIN DOWN.
SHE'S JUST IMPROVED A LOT
THROUGHOUT THE COMPETITION,
SO IT'S NERVE-RACKING.
SHE'S A GOOD GIRL.
SHE'S A WINNER.
GILLES BENSIMON
JUST CALLED NIK A WINNER.
THAT'S NOT GREAT.
LOVE THAT, LOVE THAT,
LOVE THAT.
HE'S PLAYING GAMES.
I'M THE ONE THAT
MAKES THE DECISION?
NO, YOU DON'T MAKE
THE DECISION WHO WINS.
THAT'S ME AND THE JUDGES.
WELL, THANKS, GIRLS.
YOU GUYS DID A GOOD JOB.
THAT WAS GREAT.
MODELING ISN'T SOMETHING
THAT I JUST WOKE UP
ONE DAY AND SAID
I WANT TO GO AUDITION FOR.
I HAVE BEEN TRYING THIS
SINCE I WAS A LITTLE GIRL.
IT'S JUST EXCITING
AND WEIRD TO KNOW
THAT IT COULD BE
COMING TRUE.
I FEEL LIKE
I'VE NEVER BEEN NUMBER ONE.
I'VE NEVER HAD THAT ONE THING
THAT'S MADE ME LIKE STAND OUT.
THIS HAS BEEN
MY DREAM FOREVER.
AND MAKING IT THIS FAR,
IT'S LIKE YOU JUST WANT TO WIN
SO BAD 'CAUSE YOU'RE SO CLOSE.
GOOD MORNING.
- HELLO.
- HEY!
TODAY IS REALLY LIKE
THE BIG ULTIMATE MOMENT.
SO THIS IS THE RUNWAY SHOW.
YOU'LL BE MODELING ALONGSIDE
WORKING PROFESSIONALS,
INCLUDING PAST "AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL" WINNERS
EVA AND NAIMA.
WHILE YOU GUYS WALK OUT,
WE'RE GOING TO PROJECT
THESE ELEMENTS
OF YOU GIRLS
SAYING SHAKESPEAREAN LINES.
IT IS GOING TO BE EXCITING
JUST TO SEE OURSELVES
ON A JUMBO SCREEN.
TO GET THE SUPER SCI-FI WALK,
WE HAD TO BRING OUR MISS THING.
- WHOO!
- WHAT'S GOING ON, BITCHES?
IT'S EARLY IN THE MORNIN'.
SO BASICALLY, YOU'RE
GONNA STOMP THE RUNWAY,
AND IT'S A REALLY
FAST WALK,
WIDE STRIDE.
SO ARE YOU READY TO GO
INTO HAIR AND MAKE UP?
- YEAH.
- ALL RIGHT, LET'S GO.
THERE IS SO MUCH GOING ON,
SO IT'S JUST GONNA BE
LIKE FOCUSING MENTALLY,
AND HOPEFULLY I CAN
GET IT DOWN.
I'M FROM A SMALL TOWN
IN NORTH DAKOTA,
AND THROUGH THIS WHOLE THING,
I HAVE JUST BEEN EXPOSED
TO, LIKE, THIS
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT WORLD.
AND I FEEL LIKE THIS IS MORE
THE WORLD WHERE I FIT IN.
THIS IS THE WORLD
THAT I WANT TO BE IN.
- HELLO.
HOW ARE YOU GUYS FEELING?
- SHAKY--
- A LITTLE SHAKY.
- NERVOUS--
- A LITTLE NERVOUS.
BUT YOU CAN TRANSFORM THAT
INTO SOMETHING VERY POWERFUL,
THAT SAME ENERGY.
THIS IS YOUR OPPORTUNITY.
THIS IS LIKE
YOUR LAST CHANCE.
KICK EVERYBODY
OFF THE STAGE.
COMMAND YOUR PRESENCE.
THAT'S WHAT IT'S ABOUT.
THAT'S WHY I SAY
NO REGRETS.
YOU HAVE TO DO EVERYTHING
BECAUSE YOU CANNOT WALK AWAY
REGRETTING ANYTHING.
RIGHT BEFORE IT'S TIME
TO WALK OUT ON THAT RUNWAY,
I GO IN TO MEET WITH TYRA
AND I HAVE NEVER BEEN
MORE EXCITED AND MORE
TERRIFIED AT THE SAME TIME.
THIS IS YOUR LAST CHANCE
TO TELL ME
WHATEVER YOU WANT TO TELL ME
BEFORE YOU GET ON THAT RUNWAY
AND SHOW ME WHAT YOU GOT.
I'VE NEVER FELT SO BLESSED
AND SO PROUD OF MYSELF, EVER!
AND THERE'S SO MANY PEOPLE
IN MY LIFE THAT, YOU KNOW,
"OH, YOU'LL DO GOOD," BUT THEY
NEVER REALLY BELIEVED IN ME.
AND FOR THE FIRST TIME, AND
I KNOW THIS IS LIKE CLICHÉ,
BUT FOR THE FIRST TIME,
MY FATHER, HE'S JUST
SO PROUD OF ME.
AND I JUST WANTED TO SAY
LIKE THANK YOU TO YOU,
JUST BECAUSE I'VE NEVER
FELT THIS WAY BEFORE.
AND I JUST WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT
I AM AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
I CAN JUST FEEL IT
IN MY HEART.
AND JUST THANK YOU SO MUCH.
JUST KNOW THAT YOU'RE HERE
BECAUSE OF YOU,
AND YOU NEED TO FEEL THAT
WHEN YOU'RE ON THAT RUNWAY.
- THANK YOU SO MUCH.
- YOU'RE WELCOME.
I WANT TO TAKE YOU BACK
TO THE AUDITION PROCESS,
DURING CASTING.
I REMEMBER YOU SAID
THAT YOU'VE ALWAYS FELT
SECOND BEST TO YOUR SISTER.
I JUST FEEL LIKE I HAVE
SOMETHING OF MY OWN NOW--
SOMETHING THAT I AM GOOD AT
AND THAT I CAN BE PROUD OF,
AND YOU KNOW, THAT JUST FEELS--
THAT JUST FEELS SO GOOD.
IT'S JUST HARD,
'CAUSE I WANT IT SO BAD.
TALK THROUGH IT.
THIS IS YOUR TIME FOR YOU
TO TELL ME THE REAL YOU.
THIS IS MY PASSION.
THIS IS
WHAT I WANT TO DO.
ALL-RIGHTY.
GIVE ME A HUG, MISS LADY.
THANKS SO MUCH
FOR EVERYTHING.
YOU GUYS, I KNOW THIS SHOW
IS REALLY HARD
'CAUSE YOU HAVE TO RUN,
AND IT'S A LONG RUNWAY.
BUT DON'T WALK SO FAST
THAT YOU LOSE YOUR STRUT.
AND I WANT ALL OF YOU GUYS
TO BE IN THE SHOW
LOOKING FIERCE, FABULOUS--
WORK IT AND STRUT IT.
- ALL RIGHT?
- GOT IT?
I AM EXTREMELY
NERVOUS RIGHT NOW.
I'M JUST WORRIED THAT
I'M NOT GONNA SHOW
THE JUDGES AND
EVERYONE WHAT I CAN DO.
IF I DON'T, THEN
THERE'S A CHANCE
THAT I WON'T BE AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL.
ALL RIGHT, GIRLS,
CAN WE GET YOU IN YOUR LINEUP?
- YOU GUYS SET?
- YES, SIR.
LOTS OF ENERGY!
LOTS OF ENERGY, GIRLS!
THIS IS IT!
NAIMA, GO.
"THE KING DOTH KEEP HIS REVELS
HERE TO-NIGHT.
TAKE HEED THE QUEEN
COME NOT WITHIN HIS SIGHT."
OKAY, I NEED NICOLE.
WHERE'S THE MAKEUP?
I HAD A MARK ON MY BACK
THEY NEEDED TO COVER UP,
SO I'M KIND OF STRESSING
ABOUT THAT--
JUST THINKING,
"WORK IT OUT, NICOLE.
YOU CAN DO THIS."
I NEED NICOLE.
COME.
[ applause ]
"AND THIS WEAK AND IDLE THEME
NO MORE YIELDING BUT A DREAM."
[ applause ]
YOU'RE SO FIERCE!
WHILE I'M WALKING
DOWN THE RUNWAY,
I FEEL LIKE THIS HUGE SURGE OF
ADRENALINE RUSHING THROUGH.
IT JUST FEELS LIKE YOU'RE
JUST THE CENTER OF THE WORLD.
"HE GOES BEFORE ME
AND STILL DARES ME ON.
WHEN I COME WHERE HE CALLS,
THEN HE IS GONE."
SO FIERCE!
SO GOOD!
IT JUST FEELS AMAZING
BECAUSE I WANT TO BE
ON THIS RUNWAY.
I WANT TO BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
AND THIS IS THE TIME
FOR ME TO DO IT.
THE ENERGY IS
CRAZY BACKSTAGE.
EVERYONE'S JUST THROWING
CLOTHES ON ME.
I'M LOVING IT.
I LOOK HOT!
EVA, GO.
[ applause ]
COME ON, WORK IT, NICOLE!
EVERYONE AT PANEL
ALWAYS TELLS ME, YOU KNOW,
YOU'RE SO SWEET AND INNOCENT.
I WAS KINDA TRYING TO PORTRAY
SOMETHING A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT
AND JUST SHOW MY WILD SIDE.
AND GO, NIK.
WORK IT,
COME ON, GIRL!
IT MEANS SO MUCH TO SHOW
EVERYONE IN THE WORLD
AND MYSELF THAT I AM
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THIS IS WHAT I WANT.
EVERY PASS
I DID ON THE RUNWAY,
I WAS KIND OF TRYING TO BRING
SOMETHING DIFFERENT TO IT.
AND THE THIRD TIME,
I JUST LIKE WORKED IT OUT
AND KNEW LIKE THIS IS
MY FINAL CHANCE.
THIS IS ONE
OF THE COMPETITIONS
THAT COULD MAKE ME A TOP MODEL
OR A SUPERMODEL,
AND IT MEANS SO MUCH TO ME.
IT'S A BLESSING
JUST TO BE HERE,
AND IT'D BE AN EVEN
BIGGER BLESSING TO WIN.
[ applause ]
AFTER I GOT OFF THE RUNWAY,
I REALIZED, LIKE,
THIS IS REALLY
WHAT I LOVE TO DO.
LIKE, I WANTED TO MAKE
FIVE MORE PASSES DOWN IT
AFTER I WAS DONE.
YOU ROCKED.
I HAVEN'T SEEN YOU
THIS CONFIDENT
THE WHOLE COMPETITION.
- YOU WERE SERVING IT!
- OH, THANK YOU!
I FELT PROUD OF MYSELF,
AND I AM HAPPY.
I FEEL CONFIDENT
AND I DIDN'T HAVE THAT BEFORE,
AND I HAVE IT NOW.
I KNOW NIK IS AWESOME,
AND I REALLY RESPECT HER
AS A MODEL,
BUT I JUST FEEL LIKE
THIS COMPETITION IS FOR ME,
AND I WANT TO WIN NOW
MORE THAN EVER.
YOU BOTH HAVE COME
SUCH A LONG, LONG WAY.
SO MANY YOUNG GIRLS WANT TO
BE IN YOUR PLACE RIGHT NOW.
BUT YOU'RE HERE BECAUSE
BOTH OF YOU HAVE DONE
AN AMAZING JOB
IN THIS COMPETITION.
BUT THERE CAN ONLY BE ONE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
SO WHO WILL BE?
AT THE END OF THIS JUDGING
WE'LL HAVE THAT ANSWER.
AND YOU KNOW ABOUT
OUR FABULOUS PRIZES.
THE FIRST IS A MODELING CONTRACT
WITH TOP MANAGEMENT COMPANY
FORD MODELS,
A SPREAD IN "ELLE" MAGAZINE,
AND A COVER OF "ELLE GIRL"
MAGAZINE
THAT WILL HIT
THE NEWSSTANDS IN FEBRUARY 2006.
AND A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVER GIRL
COSMETICS.
SO NOW IT IS TIME
FOR THE BEGINNING
OF YOUR INDIVIDUAL
EVALUATIONS,
AND WE'RE GOING TO START WITH
THE GHARANI-STROK FASHION SHOW.
AND YOU'RE ACTUALLY WEARING
THE CLOTHES, AND SO AM I.
WE'RE GONNA START
WITH YOU, NICOLE.
I WAS FLOORED BY YOU.
YOU HIT THE END
PERFECT LITTLE POSE,
AND THE LITTLE MMM.
FANTASTIC TO SEE
YOU'VE GOT THAT FAR.
THERE'S STILL A FEW THINGS
THAT DISTURB ME--YOUR HANDS.
YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO
WITH YOUR HANDS,
AND YOU STILL TEND
TO SLOUCH JUST A BIT.
WHEN YOU CAME OUT, I DIDN'T
ACTUALLY REALIZE FOR A SECOND
IT WAS YOU, BECAUSE
YOU ALWAYS COME ACROSS
AS SO ROMANTIC AND SOFT,
AND HERE CAME OUT
THIS STRONG, STRUTTING--
IT BLEW ME AWAY, ACTUALLY.
I WAS VERY PROUD--
A VERY PROUD MAMA.
THERE'S ONE THING THAT
I WOULD HAVE LIKED
TO SEE YOU JUST
A LITTLE MORE "I'M PISSED."
ALL-RIGHTY,
UP NEXT IS NIK.
I THOUGHT
YOU LOOKED AMAZING.
IT WAS A LITTLE BIT
BOUNCY FOR ME.
I AGREE WITH TWIGGY.
IT DID, TO ME, TAKE AWAY FROM
THE STRONG, HIGH FASHION.
NIK, YOU KNOW WHAT,
I THINK YOU LOOK INCREDIBLE.
YOU DO HAVE A JIGGLY WALK.
THAT IS NOT SUCH
A FASHION WALK.
IT WAS A BAD WALK.
TO ME, IT REMINDED ME
OF MY ERA,
WHERE THE GIRLS
HAD A SIGNATURE WALK.
SO NOW IT'S TIME TO EVALUATE
YOUR PHOTO HISTORY.
WE'RE GOING TO START
WITH FLYING HIGH IN THE SKY
AS SUPERHEROES.
GREAT SHOT.
NIK, THIS WAS A REALLY
GREAT START FOR YOU.
I LOVE THE INTENSITY
IN THE PICTURE.
NICOLE, IT WASN'T
MY FAVORITE SHOT.
I THINK SHE HAS
A 5-FINGER FOREHEAD.
KNOW WHAT A 5-FINGER
FOREHEAD IS?
- BIG FOREHEAD?
- I HAVE THAT.
ALL-RIGHTY, SO, WEEK TWO,
YOU WERE SOCIALITES
ON THE RANCH.
GOOD.
NICE. THAT'S IT.
RIGHT THERE--BANG.
- YOU BOTH NAILED IT.
- ABSOLUTELY GORGEOUS.
I DO THINK BOTH OF THEM
ARE EXTRAORDINARY PHOTOGRAPHS.
THAT'S JUST WEEK TWO
AND THAT LOOKS LIKE
YOU BEEN WORKIN'
FOR A LONG TIME.
IT SHOWS THE CAMERA
LOVES THEM BOTH.
NEXT WEEK, YOU WERE
FASHION VICTIMS,
AND THE FASHION WITCH
WAS COMING TO ATTACK YOU.
OVERDO IT!
AND YOU HAD TO RUN
ON A TREADMILL.
NIK'S LOOKS LIKE
SHE'S REALLY IN ACTION.
LOOK AT THAT--
IT'S BRILLIANT.
NICOLE, THIS IS A PICTURE TO
ME THAT'S RELYING ON PRETTY
AND NOT TAKING IT
TO THE NEXT LEVEL.
THE NEXT PHOTO SHOOT'S
VERY SEXY--
PINUP GIRLS LEANING
ON A FORD AUTOMOBILE.
- I LOVE IT.
- OH, THAT'S FANTASTIC.
THEY'VE BOTH CAPTURED THE ERA
OF THE VARGAS GIRL.
WOW, NICOLE YOU GOT BOOTY
LIKE A BLACK GIRL.
I'M JEALOUS.
THIS SAME WEEK, I DID
YOUR HAIR AND MAKEUP
WITH SOME VASELINE
AND SOME EYE LINER.
HERE ARE YOUR TWO
BEST SHOTS.
NIK'S IS
SAVAGE AND SEXUAL.
THIS IS SUBTLETY,
WHICH IS SO IMPORTANT IN
PHOTOGRAPHY AND IN MODELING.
NICOLE'S IS SO HAUNTING,
ISN'T IT?
THOSE EYES.
THESE PICTURES,
AND WHAT YOU ARE BOTH
EVOKING WITH YOUR EYES
IS WHAT A TOP MODEL
IS ALL ABOUT.
I KNOW PEOPLE MAKE FUN OF ME,
AND I AM CONSTANTLY GOING...
ALL THESE DIFFERENT THINGS
WITH MY EYES,
TRYING TO EXPLAIN
HOW IMPORTANT IT IS
TO SELL A PICTURE
WITH JUST THIS.
AND YOU BOTH
HAVE DONE THAT.
ALL RIGHT.
WE WANTED TO SEE HOW YOU DEALT
WITH CRAZY FOOLS.
WHAT IS GOING ON?
AAH!
YOU HAD TO DO A PHOTO SHOOT
WITH THE WILD BOYS.
- NIK, GREAT ENERGY.
- IT'S BRILLIANT.
GIRL, THAT'S VERY STRONG.
NICOLE, THIS LOOKS LIKE
A STILL OUT OF ACTUALLY
LIKE A MOVIE OR SOMETHING.
IT'S JUST A MOMENT
IN TIME.
ALL-RIGHTY.
NEXT, YOU HAD TO DO
A BOLLYWOOD SHOOT.
I WAS VERY EXCITED
TO SHOOT THE TWO OF YOU.
AND IT'S NOT EASY
STANDING OUT IN A CROWD.
GORGEOUS.
- BEAUTIFUL.
- NIK, I LOVE THIS PICTURE.
I FEEL AN INDIAN ESSENCE
COMING FROM YOU.
NICOLE'S SHOT.
YOU ARE STANDING OUT
IN A CROWD, TOO, MISS THING.
WHOO!
THIS IS A TIME WHEN YOU
WEREN'T RESTIN' ON PRETTY.
THE LAST AND FINAL WEEK
OF THIS COMPETITION
WAS PERHAPS THE MOST
IMPORTANT PHOTO SHOOT
BECAUSE IT WAS A COVER GIRL
PHOTO SHOOT,
AND THAT PHOTO WOULD BE
YOUR FIRST COVER GIRL AD
THAT WILL RUN NATIONALLY.
DEFINITELY
EASY AND BREEZY.
AND THE THING ABOUT THESE
PICTURES THAT I LIKE
IS THAT COVER GIRL IS
REALLY INTO HIRING MODELS.
YOU BOTH MANAGED TO BE
VERY COMMERCIAL,
BUT AT THE SAME TIME,
I KNOW I'M LOOKING AT A MODEL.
ALL-RIGHTY.
PRETTY SOON THE JUDGES ARE
GONNA START DELIBERATING.
I WANT TO HEAR
FROM BOTH OF YOU.
ANY LAST WORDS THAT YOU WANT
TO TELL THESE JUDGES
ABOUT WHY YOU SHOULD BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL?
I JUST WANT TO TELL
EVERYONE
THAT I AM SO GRATEFUL
TO BE STANDING HERE AT ALL.
AND I FEEL LIKE I HAVE GROWN
TO BE BIGGER THAN I KNEW.
MY HEART IS POUNDING SO HARD,
I THINK THAT NIK CAN HEAR IT.
IT'S REALLY SCARY,
AND I'LL BE HAPPY
NO MATTER WHAT HAPPENS.
NOW, IT IS TIME FOR
THE JUDGES TO DELIBERATE.
AND WHEN I CALL YOU BACK,
I WILL ANNOUNCE
WHO WILL BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
IT'S GONNA BE VERY
DIFFICULT TO DECIDE
WHO IS GOING TO BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL
BECAUSE I THINK THEY ARE
ALMOST EQUALLY GREAT.
LET'S START WITH NIK.
FROM DAY ONE, NIK HAS TAKEN
BEAUTIFUL PICTURES.
I THINK NIK IS
ABSOLUTELY WONDERFUL.
I THINK SHE'S
AN INCREDIBLE MODEL,
AND I THINK SHE MODELS FROM
HER HEAD TO HER TOES.
SHE IS TOO BOUNCY FOR ME,
BUT THAT IS JUST MY TASTE.
NICOLE.
PHOTOGRAPHICALLY,
THE CAMERA LOVES HER.
SHE'S A MODEL.
NICOLE HAS GOT BETTER AND BETTER
AND BETTER AND BETTER.
SHE'S LEARNT TO SMILE.
SHE LEARNT TO WALK.
- MM-HMM.
- AND LOOK AT HER TODAY.
SHE LOOKED LIKE A MODEL.
DO YOU THINK SHE WILL CRACK
UNDER FASHION PRESSURE?
I THINK SHE WILL COPE
WITH IT BETTER THAN NIK
'CAUSE I THINK NIK IS
ACTUALLY A GENTLE SOUL
AND WOULD HAVE
A MUCH TOUGHER TIME.
ONE THING ABOUT NIK'S
PICTURES--
WHEN I LOOK AT THEM,
THE FACE IS VERY SIMILAR.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME,
IT'S FIERCE.
I DON'T THINK SHE HAS
AN AMAZING BODY.
HER BODY'S SICK!
I THINK NICOLE
HAS THAT QUALITY
OF BEING A CHAMELEON
IN HER PHOTOGRAPHS.
SHE DOESN'T HAVE
JUST ONE LOOK.
THAT MAKES A MODEL.
I THINK NIK, SHE'D LOOK
GOOD IN ANYTHING.
SHE CAN SELL
SOME LINGERIE FOR SURE.
AND I'M FINDING THIS REALLY
DIFFICULT BECAUSE I--
I DO THINK THEY'RE
BOTH VERY, VERY SPECIAL.
WHICH OF THESE TWO GIRLS SHOULD
BE AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL?
NIGEL?
I THINK SHE SHOULD BE.
TWIGGY?
WE HAVE A NEW AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL.
WE'VE FINALLY REACHED
THE END OF THIS LONG JOURNEY.
BOTH OF YOU HAVE DONE
AN AMAZING JOB,
BUT THE JUDGES FEEL
ONE OF YOU CAN TRULY TAKE
WHAT AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL
MEANS AND SHARE THAT
WITH NOT JUST AMERICA,
BUT WITH THE WORLD.
I AM ABOUT TO ANNOUNCE WHO
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL IS.
AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL IS...
NICOLE.
OH, MY GOD.
THIS IS NOT HAPPENING.
AAH!
OH, MY GOD!
HERE WE GO.
CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I WANT THAT.
I WANT TO BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THAT WAS MY GOAL,
THAT WAS MY DREAM.
THAT'S WHAT I WANT.
I WANT PEOPLE
TO KNOW MY NAME.
I WANTED TO WIN SO BAD.
I DON'T KNOW.
MAYBE IT HASN'T
SUNK IN YET THAT,
YOU KNOW,
I AM NOT THAT GIRL.
(screams)
I WAS ALWAYS THE GIRL
WHO NEVER REALLY GOT,
LIKE, THAT MUCH ATTENTION.
WHOO!
AND NOW HERE I AM.
I'M A COVER GIRL
AND I'M A FORD MODEL.
DID YOU THINK THAT
THAT LITTLE INNOCENT, SWEET,
NAIVE GIRL THAT CAME INTO
CASTING AND GOT ON HER KNEES...
I'M SERIOUS.
I WANT THIS MORE
THAN I HAVE EVER WANTED
ANYTHING IN MY ENTIRE LIFE.
WAS GONNA BE UP HERE
HOLDING MY HANDS
AS AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL?
OH, MY GOD!
HELLO, HELLO, HELLO!
THROUGHOUT THIS
WHOLE COMPETITION,
I FEEL LIKE I'VE JUST
GROWN SO MUCH
NOT ONLY AS A MODEL,
BUT AS A PERSON.
THIS IS THE BEGINNING OF
SOMETHING GREAT FOR ME.
MY LIFE IS BEGINNING
RIGHT NOW.
NICOLE'S LIFE
AS A COVER GIRL.
YEAH!